hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen today I
am watching Robin Hood men in tights I
always thought that I had seen this
movie it's very similar to like all of
Monty Python which I have seen also in
high school we did Spamalot where I
played an undercover lady in the group
and I mix those up but here just for
your pleasure ISM photo of that who is
she
she's so stunning Disney's Robin Hood is
one of my absolute favorite from their
animated collection they effortlessly
captured Robin Hood and Fox form this
movie is only an hour and 40 minutes and
I hear that it's very funny so I imagine
it will do the same and I am stoked so
without further ado let's do it
actually they snap with my toes I tights
aww No
[Music]
I'm Tamara I'm Tamara in tights I watch
movies that I've never seen what a fight
about it do you I'm Tamara I'm Tamara
and tights comment to say that I'm a
lying it may be hard talking to women
but watch what you say or I'll destroy
you on Twitter I'm Tamara I'm Tamara and
tides always on guard defending the
Ghostbusters was just well it was it was
just alright okay okay okay so now this
was a film filled with very awkward
comedy and a lot of just character
stereotypes versus really fleshed out
characters and it's a story obviously
that was already there for the taking
and all of that aside it was super fun
just joke after joke after joke after
joke after joke and if all of them don't
land it's fine because there's some
really genuinely hilarious thing in this
movie the story as you all know is about
Robin Hood who escapes prison in
Jerusalem the beginning of the film and
returns home to clean it back from
Prince John
yeah I'm not doing anything it's fine so
Prince John and the sheriff of
rottingham have taken his family's
estates they also have Maid Marian in
their back pocket and he's hoping to get
his estate back and also will Maid
Marian she loosely inspired my look
today except for the mole I think we all
know where this is going
right off the bat the cast is so good I
loved them Patrick Stewart is in this
holy young Dave Chappelle he's in this I
don't know how to say carries last name
Kerry Ellis Elvis I Oh
oh I love Kerry I loved him in The
Princess Bride which is one of my
favorite movies I thought Roger Reese
rest as the sheriff of rottingham so
good oh is it King John not Prince John
Richard Lewis asking John uh had some
nice moment I think just very awkward
for me like I said in the beginning this
is a filled with super awkward comedy
and are like a really big build-up for a
joke
that's just not funny you have scene
where the prince is having this big
dinner and this big to-do and there's a
mime and the mime is going on for a bit
and the sheriff of rottingham is like
shall I kill him and the king it's such
a big bill that the Kings like a mine is
a terrible thing to waste
some of the more throwaway jokes were
the funniest to me I love that he
escapes prison in the beginning and
swims to England I wrote so Robin finds
achoo the son of a sneeze I think I
forget the dad's name and a holy young
dig Chappell Batman Dave Chappelle's
character Wow
I loved seeing him in this and it was a
surprise to me was literally he was
literally just there to say black things
so predictable and so early 90s
I'm the black guy to the point where you
could see him saying some of these lines
and it looks like he was like oh my god
I have to say that okay here I go
[Music]
I love that they made fun of her singing
the aunjanue character singing longingly
to herself in a bathroom
I liked the chastity belt gag though it
did go on and on and on and on and on
and on the whole movie but it was a it
wasn't okay fairly funny so it was fine
there were some really fun maybe simple
but still fun and effective stumps
throughout the film I think that my
favorite was the fight between Little
John and Robin Hood when they first meet
they come across
Little John who is taking tolls at the
bridge I have I can hair on my lips so
fun where is Little John and Robin who
fight with the two bowls and it's so
funny they keep breaking and now they're
like they have like this much of a pole
and it's just it's so funny
Little John eventually falls into the
river and it's like this deep and he's
like drowning it's so funny
I sent my mole on the other side I mean
you knew that was coming so the scene
that's parroting the Godfather Scarface
whatever the movie is I clearly haven't
seen it with that scene went on for so
long and I'm sure if you've seen it and
I'm sure if you watched this growing up
like I say this in every single Tammis
never seen but like if you saw this
younger I'm sure was hilarious I was
laughing out loud a lot of parts of it
but I I can imagine seeing this as a kid
I would have died I would have quoted
this all the time especially if you get
all of you know the inside jokes
especially if you've seen the Godfather
only true film buffs have seen them
let's see you went on for a really long
time where they could have put it down a
bit and just get to the point that
they're hiring someone to kill him at
the fair but right before that you get
the Men in Tights song and it's so much
fun but you go to the archery contest
I love the consulting of the script I'm
not supposed to lose wait a second he
pulls out the script I think that kind
of breaking the wall is so funny and of
course he is captured he escapes he's
married he destroys the sheriff of
rottingham and all as well then Patrick
Stewart shows up so any problem I had
with the film at first is now gone same
thing happened in Austin Powers with
Carrie Fisher throwing a Star Wars or a
Star Trek person and I'm good I've all
bored like I said there's some problems
with it of course it's definitely dated
in some of the joke-telling there's a
lot of cliches like oh there's the fat
character and all she is therefore is to
be the fat character and some of the
jokes that they do with them work and
some of them are not gonna work because
the character can't be so
one-dimensional but that being said it
was funny there are some genuine laughs
in this film you'll love it and be
slightly attracted to Kerry Ellis
you will adore the sassy guests during
the Men in Tights secret I did really
look like that yeah you'll find yourself
wondering how it can have all the
elements of a good Mel Brooks movie but
still not quite come together there were
definite points of awkwardness that were
just like I feel like one or two or
three more script revisions we're
definitely in order and then it just
didn't do it but again at the end it
does come together for me it's awkward
and clunky and I genuinely laughed I'm
so bored just what did I miss this lull
and this movie is one of my faves hoped
you loved it gotta be a man to wear
tights
you didn't miss it you made it in and I
did love it
I thought it was really fun you will
want to tip over a large number of
people like dominos yes but that has
been a longtime dream of mine not just
from this was a movie that I thought I
had seen and realized that I hadn't and
next week I am going along with the same
thing next week I'm pretty sure I want
to watch Titanic it's one of those
movies that you're like yeah of course
I've seen Titanic whatever but I've not
I've seen clips of it for sure and I
know like the the this one heart will go
on is that the song I'll be singing it
so just we're up for that after that I
think I'm gonna dive into possibly some
shows I'm thinking first season Simpsons
first season Game of Thrones
let me know it shows you would like me
to see there's a lot that I've missed
and I will see y'all next week bye I'm
Tamara I'm Tamara in tights it's true No
[Music]
[Applause]
you